This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon footprint.
You can also sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your carbon footprint or support
rainforest protection projects.
So at the end of this episode, I’m going
to say the thing that I usually say at the
end of the episodes, that thing where I thank
you all for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds
us.
But in the minutes we have before we get there,
let’s acknowledge something: most of the
time, the world that we are talking about
has come from trees and ponds and beach sand.
You know, the great outdoors, the beauty of
nature.
But you know what’s also great?
The indoors.
It’s comfy and cozy, and it’s not just
great for you.
Every time you go out, whether it’s to run
some errands or relax at the park, you bring
some friends back with you.
And when you wash your hands, some of those
friends will end up overstaying their welcome—in
your sink.
Here at Journey to the Microcosmos, we’ve
been wanting to explore the world inside our
drains for a while.
But it’s one thing to know what’s inside
a sink, it’s a whole different thing to
know what’s inside your sink.
So understandably, James—our master of microscopes—was
a little reluctant to delve into the contents
of his own home’s pipes and then share it
with the entire internet.
So instead, he used a popular vacation rental
app and rented the house next door and checked
their pipes instead.
That’s right, he went to a vacation rental,
and opened up the u-bend pipe under the bathroom
sink to gather up some of the hideous slime
he found inside.
It might help a bit to understand the u-bend
of a pipe.
One of the things you don’t want is for
your pipe to be an open-air line to the sewer...if
that were the case, you’d be able to smell
the sewer from your home.
So every drain you’ve got has a little u-shaped
bend somewhere in it and that u-bend is always
full of water, that prevents sewer gasses
from invading your home.
But a place that is always wet is going to
be full of microbes.
James has been collecting samples every day
for years, turning to all sorts of ingenious
methods in uncomfortable situations to gather
what he needs.
But he said that this was the first time he
did not enjoy the process.
So thank you, James, for your service.
We do deeply appreciate it.
By the way, now would be a good time to remind
you that James’s book “The Hidden Beauty
of the Microscopic World” is available wherever
you get your books.
It lets you hold the microcosmos in your hands
with page after page of beautiful pictures
and information.
But, back to our drain samples.
The slime that James was collecting from is
called biofilm.
You might find it in your drains or on other
surfaces, say a sink that hasn’t been cleaned
in a while.
And while it’s gross to look at from our
perspective, it’s actually kind of endearing
when you think about it from the microbe’s
point of view.
Biofilm is a sort of a community venture,
bringing together microbes that stick together
for their collective survival.
In our case, you can see the long hyphae of
fungi weaving together through the film, creating
an architecture that other non motile prokaryotes
can cling to.
Also, give us a moment to show off what we
think might be a first on our channel: archaea.
It’s not that we haven’t been able to
see archaea before.
But archaea and bacteria are both prokaryotes,
and with our previous microscopic techniques,
it’s been difficult to distinguish between
the two.
But archaea are an entirely different kingdom
of life than bacteria.
Archaea are likely more primitive, and they
have different chemistries in their cell wall
and their metabolism.
With our new fluorescence light illumination,
we can see some autofluorescence emitting
from these samples.
And we think those bits of autofluorescence
are archaea, glowing blue under the UV light.
There are other beautiful bits of autofluorescence
that have come from this gross slime as well,
like this mysterious illuminated organism.
But no matter how beautiful it is, let’s
not forget where these samples came from: a drain.
And drains are exciting for most of us.
They’re a tool, they are a fixture, a means
to maintain our environment.
They keep water contained and traveling (hopefully)
in one direction: away from us.
But for these organisms, drains are their
environment.
They’re dark, and damp, and mostly protected,
though they do go through periodic flooding
that brings new nutrients and companions.
Forming a biofilm helps the organisms contend
with whatever we throw their way, including
making the microbes inside them better able
to resist disinfectants.
Biofilms may be gross and inconvenient for
us, but they provide microbes more stability
than if they were free-floating in their planktonic
forms.
But there are limits to the protection a biofilm
can offer.
There are protist predators that are quite
content to munch on this community, which
is bad news for the organisms inside the biofilm,
but great news for the protists that eat them.
It’s also great news for more complex organisms,
like nematodes and rotifers, that need those
protists to build out the food chain that
will ultimately lead to their own dinner.
And if that food proves to be plentiful, then
they might contentedly and serenely sift through
clouds of bacteria like this rotifer.
Since we’re looking through the microscope
and not directly at the drain itself, we don’t
know what this individual was doing when it
was living in sink scum.
But proabbly this was its life back when it
was living tucked away in the u-bend of a
stranger’s house.
If you’ve been watching this channel for
a while, you might find that scene familiar,
maybe surprisingly so.
Maybe you were expecting or hoping for swamp
monsters in the slime, something completely
wild and different from other things that
we see under the microscope.
But the familiarity is kind of the point.
These things in our sinks are there because
we put them there, bringing them from the
surfaces around us.
It’s an ecosystem of our own making, structured
by our architecture and fed by our own daily
adventures and misadventures.
This house’s drain is like a little history
of the people who have stayed there before,
a microbial guest book, if you will.
And that extends to all sorts of drains, not
just the ones in our homes.
After all, there are drains in buildings and
facilities where we work and eat and visit.
And they all have their own little ecosystems
fed by whatever is going on in that building.
Sometimes those ecosystems are innocuous.
In food processing plants that make cheese,
for instance, scientists have found the microbes
used to make cheese lingering in the those
drains.
But sometimes the ecosystems have their own
monsters, like the pathogenic bacteria found
in hospital drains.
We might be studying this house’s drains
for fun and education.
But for hospitals, those drains are both a
record and indicator of disease, making them
a concern for public health while also providing
us with the means to understand what those
concerns might need to be.
Because of course, no ecology exists on its
own.
The drain isn’t just the unseen world around
us, it’s an unseen world that we make and
interact with all the time, in stories of
causes and effects that seem distant from
the creatures idling inside.
It may not be born in the most elegant of
ways, and it may never be beautiful to look
at from afar.
But up close, even a drain can be breathtaking.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for supporting
this episode of Journey to the Microcosmos.
Wren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon footprint, and make a monthly
contribution to offset it by funding projects
that plant trees and protect rainforests.
You’ll answer a few questions about your
lifestyle so you can see what your carbon
footprint is, and they’ll also show you
ways you can start reducing it.
But no one can reduce their carbon footprint
to zero, so when using Wren, you can offset
what you have left.
Once you sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your carbon footprint, you’ll
receive updates from the tree planting, rainforest
protection, and other projects you support.
It’s gonna take a lot to end the climate
crisis, but you can help by learning more
at wren.co
Use the referral link in the description and
we'll protect an extra 10 acres of rainforest
when you sign up!
All of the people on the screen right now,
they are our patreon patrons.
They’re the people that let us have a YouTube
channel where we explore the inside of the
drains of vacation rentals.
And that kind of person, we can all admit,
is a special kind of person.
So, we appreciate them very much.
If you would like to become a Patreon patron,
you can go to patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
jam & germs on Instagram, or on TikTok.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.